♪ ♪ ♪
- On pourrait croire qu'Elodie
Fougeres était prédestinée à
un retour à la terre.
- On s'est donné une bonne tape
de main à la fin.
- Le travail est physique,
exigeant, le salaire, lui :
14,25 $ de l'heure.
ELODIE FOUGERES
- Ce n'était pas nécessairement
pour le salaire que j'ai
commencé cette expérience,
c'était vraiment plus pour
apprendre puis vivre
l'expérience de travailler sur
une ferme.
- C'est là qu'elle habite,
en échange d'un loyer modique.
Elle évite ainsi les frais de
déplacement, d'autant plus que
ses sorties se font rares,
salaire minimum oblige.
- Là, je fais juste lire mste ln
livre dans le petit champ puis
je médite, puis je fais mon yoga
puis... Je fais mon yoga ici au
lieu d'aller dans le studio.
Fait que ça aussi, c'est une
dépense de moins.
- (journaliste): Tout ce qui est
gratuit.
- Exact, oui.
Sans avoir l'appartement ici à
la ferme, sans habiter proche
puis avoir des légumes, je sais
pas comment je réussirais à
m'en sortir, avec le salaire que
je fais. Je sais pas le nombre
de personnes qui travaillent
encore au salaire minimumaujour.
- (journaliste): 300 000 au
Québec, présentement, environ.
- 300 000 personnes?
(soupir)
♪ ♪ ♪
- 301 100 travailleurs plus
précisément, selon les dernières
estimations du ministère de
l'Emploi. C'est 8 % des salariés
de la province.
La plupart ont entre 15 et
24 ans, plus de la moitié sont
des femmes, et dans 70 % des
cas, les emplois occupés sont
dans les secteurs du commerce au
détail, de l'hébergement et de
la restauration.
- Les travailleurs de SOS Vélo,
un organisme d'insertion à
Montréal, ont longtemps fait
partie de ces statistiques.
LAURENCE DUBOIS, respo. services
psychosociaux, SOS Vélo
- Moi, je voyais des gens
juste qui n'y arrivaient pas,
je voyais des gens qui n'étaient
pas capables de s'alimenter à
chaque schaque schaque schaque .
- Mais depuis mai dernier,
l'organisme pige dans son budget
déjà serré pour offrir un taux
horaire d'un dollar de plus que
le salaire minimum.
STÉPHANE TREMBLAY, travailleur
en formation, SOS Vélo
- Chaque sous est compté.
Chaque sous est compté.
- Pour Stéphane Tremblay,
l'effort est apprécié, mais
reste insuffisant pour affronter
l'inflation, surtout pendant la
recherche d'un nouveau logement.
- T'sais, j'ai regardé pour
un trois et demi, c'est
1500 piastres. 1100,
1500 piastres pour un 3 et demi.
J'arriverai pas à payer ça là.
Oublie ça. Fait que je vais me
retrouver à 56 ans en chambre.
Ça me stresse, oui, oui.
- C'est justement pour allégerce
plusieurs organismes demandent
une augmentation immédiate du
salaire minimum, pour le faire
passer à au moins 18 $ l'heure.
VIRGINIE LARIVIÈRE, Collectif
pour un Québec sans pauvreté
- 18 $ de l'heure, c'est
vraiment le minimum que ça prend
pour être en mesure de penser
sortir de la pauvreté;
c'est-à-dire d'être capable de
payer le mettre de
la nourriture sur la table, de
pouvoir s'habiller, se déplacer.
- Ça ferait que ce serait des
personnes qui pourraient payer
leur épicerie, qui pourraient
lieu de survivre.
- J'ai beaucoup de doutes sur la
pertinence de cette demande.
- Mais pour cet économiste,
une augmentation aussi
importante serait néfaste pour
bien des entreprises, ellesauss.
OLIVIER RANCOURT, économiste,
Institut économique de Montréal
- Les entrepreneurs ne sont pas
opposés, conceptuellement, à
augmenteires, mais ne
peuvent pas le faire, tout en
restant rentables. Et
évidemment, si une entreprise
ferme, tout le monde qui
travaille là perdent leur emploi
nt pas mieux avancés.
- Selon lui, la solution devrait
plutôt passer par des mesures
plus ciblées, pour aider
les parents à faibles revenus
notamment.
- Ce serait génial.
- Stéphane Tremblay est, sansgri
prônent une augmentation majeure
et rapide du salaire minimum.
Mais en attendant, ses objectifs
restent modestes, devant
la hausse du coût de la vie.Peuu
gagnes, la pomme coûte le même
prix à l'épicerie.
- Oui, mais, t'sais, des fois,
m'en acheter une, ce serait
peut-être le fun!